hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
june 21st what's going on how
are you how's it going everyone
everyone how are you i hope you had a
happy
father's day father's day i hope
everybody uh you know
hope you had a good time you know i
bitched enough about my father's day to
make sure that my wife realized
that it's called father's day
not father's morning
not father's morning and into the early
afternoon and then the
[ __ ] goes back to normal ah no
father's day all day all day baby all
day
who are you honoring this guy
who's the man with the [ __ ] jumps that
keeps the lights on
that's right say it repeat after me
right this is my day
so i'm in the middle of my day right now
of course i still have to do a podcast
you know
but you know whatever i'm still enjoying
myself
i've been chilling out you know my wife
was asking me she's like what do you
want to do for
for father's day do you want to go to
brunch
can you believe that can you believe the
[ __ ] nerve
that beautiful saint of a woman that
married this [ __ ] [ __ ] can you
believe that do i want to go to brunch
no i don't want to do your [ __ ] on my
day
so she laughed she goes all right well
what do you want to do then
and i said nothing
absolutely [ __ ] nothing
nada zero zilch
big l right on my forehead
okay i want to do nothing
like an overpaid free agent dozen of
playoffs
i want to do what they do nothing
and that's what i've been doing you know
she took the kids out and everything but
i'm gonna go meet up with them because i
was like listen i mean i want to hang
out and not do anything but i want you
guys to leave
i love you guys i was actually playing
with my son this morning man i had such
a blast with
him he doesn't know how to say my name
but the second he sees me he goes ball
ball ball because he knows he knows
what's going down
he knows the energy is going up and he
gets excited
so um this morning i was rolling the
ball to him and he was laying on his
side
he actually decided that he was going to
kick the ball
laying sideways tell you this kid is
coordinated this is not
the ramblings of an overly proud dad
who's head over heels in love with his
son i'm telling you this kid has got
skills
he's going to make all the dreams i
couldn't come true
no pressure son no um
my daughter now can like throw and catch
ridiculously we have so much fun
and uh i'm telling you like that's
that's part of like you got to teach
your kids how to do [ __ ]
you know and not only do [ __ ] you got to
teach them with both hands
right righty lefty switch hit the whole
[ __ ] thing you just turn it into a
game they learn how to do [ __ ]
they have confidence especially for the
girls too because that [ __ ] [ __ ]
where they just stand around and watch
boys do stuff
you know i i don't want you know my wife
wasn't like that she told me when she
was a kid
when she was in uh
she wasn't that kind she knows she's
like i'm gonna stand around and watch
boys play in sports i'm gonna go do [ __ ]
oh jesus that's what i married
and that's his finer points yeah the ups
and downs oh jesus
so um i've just been chilling out i i
started watching
uh yet another movie
i found this website i'll give it to you
it's called
collarder.com c-o-l-l was that collider
i'm so dumb i have no idea
c-o-l-l-i-d-e-r
dot com and it has um
what does it have here it had all of
these let me get to the top here
33 great 70s films that time forgot
there's some [ __ ] crazy ones i just
started to watch the first one that's on
the list
um no not the first one the second one
investigation of a citizen above
suspicion which is weird because it
seems like
uh the whole movie was like
they dubbed in the um
the uh the dialogue afterwards like they
lost all the sound i don't know what's
going on i mean everything's in italian
as far as like the uh the credits go but
it looks by the way their lips
are moving is that they're speaking
english but maybe the english was so bad
that they just had some [ __ ]
english actors english-speaking people
dub them in i don't know what but i am
enjoying it so far
but i saw a [ __ ] movie that all of
you right now
you need to stop you need to neglect
your family
and you need to sit down right now if
you are a fan of [ __ ] dustin hoffman
harry dean stanton um
uh uh gary busey and jake busey
who i worked with a long time ago uh his
first acting role ever literally plays
gary busey's son in this incredible
[ __ ] movie
called uh straight time which i'm gonna
i'm gonna look this up right now so i
get i get this story right
um it was basically
uh dustin hoffman oh a teresa russell
is unbelievable in it
m emmett walsh all of these great
character actors and
edward bunker who's actually the
he was doing time i think in san quentin
i'm not sure
but he wrote this book about what it was
like to do time
and get out of jail and all that stuff i
guess i never read the book but dustin
hoffman read the book fell in love with
it wanted to do this movie
the movie came together edward bunker is
in it if you recognize that name
um it's because quentin tarantino
evidently is a big fan of the movie
straight time and when he did reservoir
dogs
edward bunker um who wrote the book that
straight time
is based on played one of the reservoir
dogs who unfortunately for his character
gets killed
spoiler alert jesus christ the movie's
only been out for [ __ ] 30 years
um in the robbery um so they all tie
together
and um did i already talk about this i
feel like i already talked about this
i think i talked about it on the last
podcast sorry i've just been so [ __ ]
busy but uh if you
missed my last podcast definitely go
check it out
um or maybe i was talking to derosa
about it dude harry dean stanton
is just amazing in that movie when you
meet his character the situation that
he's involved in you you just got to
check the thing out
kathy bates one of her first movies
she's in it um
it's just a uh really gritty incredible
i don't think i've ever seen dustin
huffman play a character
like this guy and uh it also takes place
in la in the 70s
so it has all those [ __ ] cars that i
love and
um just takes me back to this [ __ ]
time where my life was simple most
people's lives weren't
uh speaking of that speaking of that a
buddy of mine who did some work on my
old truck
um he found this old ford
four-door like ltd an
original owner um
[Music]
or maybe the second owner but like the
car is all original
except listen to this [ __ ] it's a 1970
right
it has a second gas
tank in the trunk that was added
after you know the obviously aftermarket
put this thing in there
because of the gas shortage in the early
70s and they never took it out and they
still have it how [ __ ] cool is that
you know that reminds me like
you know uh when you watch the uh jay
leno's garage
like literally you know i would say
at least 30 of your love for whatever
vehicle is the story
i mean you got to love the way the car
looks and everything but if it's got the
great story
on top of it um how [ __ ] cool is that
i mean now that's literally like that is
like a statement of just
what the car went through where this
country was at
and the [ __ ] of the gas shortage
because here we are 50 [ __ ] years
later
i remember i remember those lines that's
how old i am
and um and the speed limit just kind of
kept coming
down and down down to 55 miles an hour
and i was talking to my grandfather at
the time going like
going you know girl by that time i
learned how to drive the speed limit was
going to be like 30 and he was like he
was smoking a pipe he's like oh no no
son it's not going to come down that far
um but also there but there was
talk about how there wasn't gonna be
any more we were running out of gas and
there was this big panic by people
sitting in those lines
that they that they then that became all
of those [ __ ] horrible
at least the american ones were [ __ ]
horrible it's really a bad time for cars
for america
from sort of the mid 70s
until uh i mean you know a major portion
of the 80s then i feel like we came back
in the 90s but that was a really
dark dark [ __ ] time with the chevy
chevette
the ford escort the pontiac t1 thousands
the [ __ ] sunbirds the cadillac went
down to like the size of a [ __ ]
um a ford fairmont it was just bad
the whole [ __ ] thing did ugly those
dodge k
cars that saved chrysler i mean now like
people go and buy them because they're
like the [ __ ] ugliest cars ever and
there's just something funny about them
to see
i love the one that had the wood siding
on it i want to say doug stanhope had
had one of those when he was out here in
l.a because everything he does is
[ __ ] hilarious
even the car he buys was hilarious um
but anyway so this movie you got to see
it's straight time it's on
amazon prime um
and they have like all of these these
amazing amazing movies so and i watched
this other movie called images which i
can't remember if i told you that about
robert altman one of his first ones it's
about a woman slowly losing her [ __ ]
mind
and uh that's another good one too so
that's it all right
oh billy's cinephile now how would
happen to me what happened to me
um i'll tell you what happened to me
last night i went out
like saturday night is my night with my
wife friday night was for the girlfriend
saturday night was for the wise what was
that it was uh
[ __ ] uh good fellas
i know it was friday nights for the
wives and then
saturday night was for the girlfriends
it's like jesus christ
maybe if you had a stay-at-home wife she
could be excited but still she worked
she worked all day with the [ __ ] kids
i guess she would on saturday too i
don't know
[ __ ] take her out friday all right
sweetheart i'm going out saturday you're
wearing a nicer suit
what's going on with you um so anyway we
go out on saturday nights say
that happened because of the pandemic i
mean i'm a stand-up comedian i never had
a date night ever on saturday night and
you know ever even before i was a
comedian because i was a [ __ ] loser
who couldn't get a girlfriend
um i was not a loser i was an abused
child who was introverted there you go
put it on society
um no i was getting it white [ __ ]
fire
[ __ ] orange hair all right i was an
absolute freak i looked like bernie from
room 222. all right
the deck was stacked against me all
right i was like the [ __ ] new orleans
pelicans
you know if you could put that franchise
in
a into a man
it would be me in my early 20s um
those poor [ __ ] people they're on
their way to losing zion you can hear
he's already bitching oh they don't have
the right [ __ ] pieces they don't get
the [ __ ] money
um unbelievable
it's not [ __ ] believable that's how
they run it people seem to enjoy it so
anyway speaking of that so last night we
ended up going out
um we had we had such a
[ __ ] great time um
now that i'm not an angry lunatic who
like all of his [ __ ] [ __ ]
from 30 years ago comes up every time
somebody cuts him off in traffic
and which would just instantly ruin the
night
so i don't do that [ __ ] anymore um
and we just had this easy [ __ ] night
it was amazing and um
you know i like writing ideas and [ __ ]
he always has good ideas for like tv
shows we always like kick him around so
we were hanging out
and she goes hey she goes you want to go
to a cigar bar
you know we'll kick this idea around you
know you have a cigar i'll [ __ ] hang
out or whatever and i'm just like
absolutely this is like the perfect
night just had a great meal
you know and uh so we went out went to
the cigar bar and i come walking in and
lo and behold
game seven fourth quarter of the
brooklyn nets
versus the milwaukee bugs is on i'm like
holy [ __ ]
you know i'm a hockey guy i mean i know
i knew i was missing the islanders game
um but i came walking in and everybody
in like the place was [ __ ]
you know it was intense in a cigar bar
kind of way you know what i mean
and uh everybody was going nuts
and i'm just thinking like all right i
know milwaukee's keeping it close but
like you know they got all these [ __ ]
superstars
you know and then i saw kyrie irving
irving wasn't playing game seven because
he twisted his ankle
which is [ __ ] hilarious if you watch
hockey
um i twisted my ankle i can't be there
for you on game seven
sorry guys he was walking around fine
his street clothes um
but anyway so i watched the game and
uh i got to tell you something man kevin
durant
you know i'm done giving that guy [ __ ]
for [ __ ] piling on with the warriors
that guy
is a [ __ ] reptile
just ice water in his veins and when he
hit that [ __ ] what i thought was a
three-pointer
my dumb ass i thought they were up at
the that point i thought he had iced the
game
and my [ __ ] eyes are going i was like
oh is it a tie score
he's looking at me um i actually watched
that and when his they cut to his mother
i remember thinking like what is that
gotta feel like
to see your son do that at that level
it's just got to be on
it's got to be unbelievable i can't
believe it's my kid
um so they go into overtime
and i'm just looking at the milwaukee
bucks and i'm like this game is over
they already lost and people laugh and
go nah come on the games keep going oh
they quit
they quit they're like yeah you know
what you're talking about i go listen
i've quit enough in life to know what it
looks like right i was killing
i was killing in that sick i killed so
hard in that [ __ ] cigar bar
i didn't have to go to a set next door
because i was saying yeah
maybe i can jump on just do a little
time whatever i [ __ ] got so many
goddamn laughs
having such a good time watching that
amazing amazing amazing game
and uh i don't know man i was wrong i've
been so [ __ ] wrong
um maybe you guys have always known that
about me but i'm sort of discovering how
much i've been wrong about [ __ ] so
much [ __ ] here in sports
lately i think now that i got the kids i
just i just don't have enough time
to pay attention because um
i did not see this islanders run coming
i did not see this canadians run coming
i didn't see any of this [ __ ]
and i thought you know you look at the
[ __ ] brooklyn nets with all those
superstars and all that [ __ ] i'm like
they got it i don't give a [ __ ] if one
of them's hurt the other guy
[ __ ] has a [ __ ] ingrown toenail or
whatever the hell the problem you got a
handking problem
um you know this the bucks don't have
enough
firepower to beat this team and lo and
behold they ended up
uh they ended up winning i just had so
much fun and it was kind of cool that my
wife was there too she's like wow man
this is like really
this is a good time i'm like yeah man
sports get into it
jesus christ watch something you know
she's social
see she she's social so if she's just
home with me
you know she takes me for granted i'm
like that lamp in the corner every
morning you wake up and there it is
after a while you stop seeing it
so you know it takes a bunch of other
guys flipping out for her to get [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you know
this is the thing yes yes this is the
thing
so congratulations to the milwaukee
bucks
all the fans of course a bunch of new
fans because anytime you have a run
there's a bunch of new fans but all the
hardcore
milwaukee buck fans all the way back to
sydney moncrave still waiting for your
first [ __ ] nba championship
since [ __ ] 19th somebody say 71
when lual cinder let's see if i look
if i look let's see if i'm right
milwaukee bucks
nba championship i'm going to say 71
71 71 bam
here's one for you yes i left this long
message on a buddy of mine's phone
where you know i was thinking about the
toronto maple leafs in their 54-year
drought
which is really interesting 54 years
now if you're a hockey fan that 54
should stick out
especially if you're a ranger fan that
was how long
their drought lasted and they were
considered cursed
they went from 1940 to 1994.
54 years without letting lord stanley
right now what's crazy about that
is that that was 27 years ago
and 27 years ago when they won their
first cup in 54 years
the tampa tampa bay the toronto maple
leafs were 27 years into their drought
and no one was saying that they were
cursed because detroit had still not won
and neither had chicago detroit had won
since like the mid 50s
chicago hadn't won since 60 or 61.
so let's talk droughts here i think
droughts are overrated
and curses and all of that type of [ __ ]
i think there has to be
like now that there's so many [ __ ]
like i understand why the the
the red sox were considered cursed
um i mean obviously they went 86 years
but also
it's like dude you guys weren't winning
red sox were not winning championships
when there was like 12 teams in the
league
um so i understand them getting [ __ ]
like that and i guess you can still give
it
i guess the maple leafs haven't won
since the expansion six where they went
from six to twelve there's still no
excuse what the [ __ ] has happened with
those guys
however if you really look at the
numbers
you know if there's 30 teams all it
takes is about four or five of them
to go on a run and once they start
winning
like multiple championships it it
becomes like the michael jordan thing
where all of those
you know patrick ewing charles barkley
um um what's his [ __ ] name there on
on on the
portland trailblazers from houston ah
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
clyde uh clyde drexler all of those
great dominique wilkins all of those
guys who never won championships
because maybe dominic dominic sort of
overlapped the larry bird era and magic
johnson but like all of those people who
didn't win
is totally understandable if you look at
the nba in the in the 80s it was
basically
the lakers in the celtics sixers got one
and then you went into the pistons era
where they went back to back and then it
was like the [ __ ]
chicago bulls houston winning two so
you're talking about from 1980
to 1998 18
nba titles up for grabs
the lakers the celtics
the sixers the pistons
the bulls and the rockets six teams got
all 18 of those
so right there there goes two [ __ ]
deck and then along comes the spurs
that are gonna grab five and then along
comes the pile on lakers that are gonna
grab
five right
then all of a sudden you're in a [ __ ]
drought
that's how easy it happens so but i
don't think it's like
as bad as it sucks for the fans but it's
not as like
god how the [ __ ] do you go 50 [ __ ]
years without winning easy there's 30
teams
all you need is like four or five of
them to win like five
there's half that time and it's [ __ ]
over
so let's look at since 1967.
since the last time the leafs won it as
far as off the top of my head
um the canadians have won
10. they won 68 69 71 73
76 77 78 79 that's eight right there
then they won in 86
and then 93 they there's 10 there goes a
decade
so now you're down to 44 [ __ ] years
all right off their 54-year curse
then who's next uh the edmonton oilers
won
five 84 85
87 88 and 90.
all right there's 15 years in islanders
won
four let's see did the uh
did the how many of the the penguins
i'm gonna have to look this up penguins
won two with mario and then i think
three yeah so they've won five so that's
five
ten fourteen plus the canadians ten
then the devils won like three
the red wings won four there's another
seven that are out the [ __ ] window
like i don't even know how many teams
have even like
it's really hard is what i'm saying for
like the saint louis blues
i mean for them to go 50 something years
to finally [ __ ] win it
um i guess i kind of understand why they
won it the way they did it's just like
listen
we're not going to win it playing hockey
let's just [ __ ] run the goaltender
and punch
the better players in the face till
they're [ __ ] injured then we'll win
the series
[ __ ] you blows sorry uh
the capitals who else was like a one and
doner
calgary got one in 89.
yeah so i'm just saying it's very easy
that was a long long [ __ ] way to go
to say that it's really easy to get into
a [ __ ] drought that's all i'm saying
people
so lay off these [ __ ] coaches okay
it's very difficult
i'll tell you what else is difficult is
for me to sit there and understand
how like i really thought like okay the
islanders got by the bruins that's sort
of their cup
tampa's the defending champions i mean i
know it's 2-2
they did go up 2-1 i still think that
they have
an advantage um in this series but the
thing about the islanders is you have to
play with the lead with those guys and
that also includes games like i don't
see them going down 3-2
and winning that series they have to win
the next one and i would almost say
win both of them i think they need to
run the table i just i'm saying it right
now
haven't watched 20 minutes of [ __ ]
hockey during the regular season i
watched more than that
i don't think the tampa bay lightning
win at game seven
against the islanders all right
and then the canadians all right
everyone they're gonna lose this round
they lose that he's a
good [ __ ] team with a great coach and
they got a great [ __ ] goaltender who
finally has the people in front of him
and uh as they say as they say they they
got hot at the right time so we shall
see
i think the canadians are going to take
that [ __ ] series
um and you know something the old me
two podcasts ago was all pissed off
about it and now it's like bill
why don't you just [ __ ] enjoy this
great coaching and this
[ __ ] really fun hockey they're
[ __ ] fun team to watch i hate to say
it they are
they are you know what and and whether i
hate them or not is not going to
affect whether they win on it or lose it
so i might as well just sit there enjoy
it
you know i got wife and kids walking
around the house and we sitting
downstairs like jesus [ __ ] christ
that's boarding [ __ ] boarding i'm not
gonna do that i can't do that
i can't do that to people i've done it
enough
congratulations to mark marquez
the king is back surprise surprise ufc
reference
um i missed the race um i'm gonna watch
it i'm i'm a member
on motogp uh their website i'm gonna
watch it it's so [ __ ] exciting
that he has come back and he makes
everybody better
and um the fact that you know i heard
was a great come-from-behind victory
he's behind in the points it's just
going to be i'm calling it right now
even though i'm wrong about everything
in sports now it's going to be [ __ ]
insanity
watching him trying to run down uh who's
the guy who's
i always forget his [ __ ] name fabio
cuatro i think he's leading the points
and now he's coming all right
like that disney movie i only saw once
but everybody always makes a reference
to the little [ __ ] lion
gets kicked out by the evil line what
what were you saying [ __ ]
fabio's the [ __ ] evil no i'm not
saying that i'm just saying it's like a
disney movie
no if a disney movie if the disney movie
made it i don't want to do that it's a
bad joke now consider what all right
[ __ ] that joke all right um
so what else what else has been fun in
my life
um oh just continuing to
go down my little country
uh outlaw rabbit hole and just listening
to more and more [ __ ]
and uh just continuing to play it in the
car while i drive my daughter around
wherever the hell we're going because
she's on summer vacation now which is
[ __ ] awesome
it's you know you know what's cool about
your daughter being on summer vacation
it's like you're on vacation
too because you don't have to get up do
her hair and
drive her to school you get to chill out
you know
sleep in make waffles around 9 9 30.
you know it's still the end of a
pandemic i don't have anywhere to go
this is [ __ ] great
i swear to god man if i could have just
been a little bit smarter with my money
and invested
right but where would you invest you
can't invest in real estate at pandemic
these people can't pay their rents what
are you going to charge them
maybe that guy kicks them out to do what
who's going in there nobody has a job
you know [ __ ] rent out your building
only to the scientists who came up with
the vaccine that half the people don't
want to take
no you can't [ __ ] do that um
yeah i think i would retire
um yeah i think i could [ __ ] do it i
wouldn't retire retire but i just would
be a local comic i would just do spots
out here in la
just be the local guy podcasting
i mean i could [ __ ] do it if i wanted
to
just start doing that old man diet you
know hey i have a couple of fake news
and
some saltine crackers for breakfast
[Laughter]
you know just start eating those little
bird [ __ ] meals that they eat
and shuffle around the block oh my god
i'm not gonna do it but if i did if i
retired i would start getting the
newspaper delivered to my house
and every morning i'd start drinking
coffee i never drank coffee you have a
little [ __ ] espresso or some [ __ ]
with a cappuccino or something
you know and i'd smoke a little [ __ ]
nub
and i would do how great does that life
sound
retired i love the idea of being all
used up and nobody has any use for you
anymore
it's [ __ ] great
nobody [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] the phone
doesn't ring anymore and you just
[ __ ] sit there reading the paper
just talking to yourself you know
you look at a headline yeah jesus christ
look at this
what the [ __ ] is going on with this
country you just
reading this stuff falling asleep waking
up [ __ ] ash on your
t-shirt all right it's getting a little
sad but anyway maybe i just need a
vacation
um vacation i haven't done the road and
over yet
um all right so yesterday as part of my
pre
um as part of my pre
uh father's day i went up and uh
flew a helicopter and i went up to the
airport where i was flying
out of and because of the june gloom and
possibly a fire
visibility was below 10 miles
so basically uh instrument weather is
is uh anything three miles statute miles
or less
visibility so it was down to seven
so i'm like well [ __ ] that i don't fly
unless it says one zero clear day that's
what the [ __ ] i'm all about i'm not like
these people that fly for a living who
go
all right we gotta figure out a way
through this [ __ ] i'm not doing that so
but i wanted to fly so i just flew the
pattern
which is you just take off
either bang a right or a left and then
you
fly parallel down the runway and you
bang a right or a left and then you just
come in low approach you just do that
for like an hour and it's fun because
it's actually
um there's a lot of you're working on
most of your skills
taking off landing hovering
um the speed you're supposed to be at
the altitude you're supposed to be
and all that and all that was a little
bit rusty so it was really fun to uh
to do that and then it was fun too when
i went in to land
because what i was flying was a uh sort
of a unique helicopter
a newer one um so there was some guy on
the ground
standing next to his helicopter and he
was filming me so he's filming me as i'm
coming in
and then there's a spa the pad where i'm
landing it on
is in between two helicopters his and
then another helicopter where they're
already run up the engine
and this guy's filming me just because
he likes the helicopter you know
everybody's into
what people are flying so i'm like okay
don't pay attention to the guy filming
yeah you got to set it on a [ __ ] pad
and it was kind of fun it was like all
right this is like david letterman
sitting right there
no just block it out block that out go
out do your [ __ ] jokes
i kind of used those muscles and i was
able to do the best job but i was able
to set it down
you know i act like a catcher where was
kind of a ball and i was acting like it
was a strike i was a little bit over to
the left i wasn't too pleased with it
but it was good enough
it was great when i got out and i looked
at it i said i [ __ ] hate myself and i
said no
i don't done with that [ __ ] too saying i
[ __ ] hate myself
so then i towed the thing back to the
hangar and uh
this little honda four-wheeler
and i was like you know what [ __ ] this
man there's nobody around it was just
like nobody around so i just [ __ ]
closed the hanger i just cruised around
the airport on that four-wheeler
running it through the gears i'm just
having a [ __ ] great time
thinking about how awesome my life is
and uh who knew who knew that night i
was gonna go out to go to a cigar bar
and watch that game seven just had a
[ __ ]
great day so i don't know is this weird
for you guys me being happy
i'm i guarantee you i'm still going to
be a [ __ ] lunatic
on stage um because i did a set at the
comedy store thursday night i did two of
them
and um oh my god i was having a good
time
i was having a great [ __ ] time and i
haven't even gotten into because of
short sets i haven't even gotten into
what the [ __ ] i want to talk about um
in this hour and uh whatever this is
gonna be
so once again i am really excited about
this vegas gig coming up
i'm doing some tune-up shows around la
that will be announced
soon where i'm doing full sets all right
full contact karate comedy
i'll be doing around town and um
working this [ __ ] out and i don't know
what it's gonna be i'm gonna figure it
out
so uh when i get those dates i will let
you know all right and with that
let's read some of the advertising here
oh look
me undies me undies smoking a [ __ ]
stick
me undies beyond these you got too many
free agents you guys are dicks
i'm rooting for the other [ __ ] team
even though most of guys i've never seen
i don't know their names but i'm happy
they won
and milwaukee got a day in the sun you
[ __ ] cheesy eaters
don't [ __ ] shart your [ __ ] undies
all right me
all right me undies summer is coming in
hot literally
literally but with me undies breathable
and soft as heck fabrics i love that
they kept it family friendly
um you can soak up the sun and feel
cool for the summer with a mix of
classic
[ __ ] colors just in case you guys
think i'm going all country on you
family values and adventurous prince
perfect for summer express yourself in
your own unique way
because my undies believes that comfort
is more is about more
than what's touching your skin it's
about feeling comfortable in your skin
i only wear me undies because they're
the softest underwear i've ever felt and
they send them to me for free
had to be honest uh designed to be the
softest thing you've ever worn they are
very soft
they're very soft me undies are
energized by creative
creativity and made for self-expression
available in size and
extra small to 4xl
uh me undies has countless styles and
prints to choose from so your buns can
have more fun
meundies has a great offer from my
listeners
my listeners for any first-time
purchasers get 15
off and free shipping myani's also has
their problem-free philosophy man
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason man they'll refund it or
exchange it man no caveats no questions
to get your 15
off your first order order
true giving me orders uh free shipping
go to meundies.com that's meundies.com
for 15 off your first order and free
shipping i couldn't remember where that
quote came from that was scarface
hey frank the only thing that gives
orders around here is bulls
um
the right outfit can bring out something
special in us
and with indochito creating your best
look
could be um more affordable than you
think
talk about any special occasions that
have been postponed over the past year
or any events that are coming up soon
that you're looking forward to i'm going
to a wedding
you know a lot of weddings were
postponed or people did them over
zoom you know if it's some you know
gold digger marrying an old guy she's
like i don't have a pandemic or not i
got to marry this [ __ ] before he dies
so i get my [ __ ] you know talons in
him
um it may have been a while since the
last time you had an excuse to dress up
but whenever the next chance is make the
absolute most of it within no cheeto
did you shop online or visit a showroom
describe your experience
oh my god the clothes went on forever
how did you personalize your clothing
describe how wearing your custom piece
makes you feel
i didn't do any of this [ __ ] you didn't
tell me to do it i would have done it i
would have [ __ ] got a [ __ ] cheap
oh jesus i can't see that
cheap compared to that [ __ ] monkey
suit i bought for the goddamn grammys
and then i was on the internet
and it went still stinks
[ __ ] credit card was redlining that's
one of those things where the second i
tried the pants on the [ __ ] credit
card company was already calling me up
are you trying on an expensive suit you
know any [ __ ] place to go
anyway every piece is made to your exact
measurement and you can customize every
detail
choose everything about your suit from
the fabric lapel monogram and statement
lines
you can create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly the best part is
started just 3.99 with all
customizations included
shop for your next best look or book a
virtual style consultation at
indochino.com right now
you can get 50 bucks off your first
purchase at 3.99
or more by using code bird checkout
that's dollars off a purchase of three
nine or niner or more at i n d
o c h i n o dot com
promo code burp okay here we go
all right well now now we are getting
into it we are getting into the
questions the things that you people
want to hear
listen are you broke are you so [ __ ]
up that you don't want to talk to a
therapist because you can't be in the
same room with another human being
why don't you call abundance you right
into a bald freckled [ __ ]
who has no training whatsoever you know
let's see what he has to say about [ __ ]
all right things i should have said oh
this is this
i'll tell you right now i'll tell you
right now this segment is blowing up
things i should have said we've all been
there something happens
right you're shocked the moment passes
it's too late and then as you're driving
home a year later
two years later [ __ ] on your deathbed
you're like you know what the [ __ ] i
should have said
i saw one of those moments i was
watching uh my wife had on the
kardashians
i've just quit i've tapped out i'm like
the [ __ ]
maple leafs okay i'm up three games to
one and i finally just said you know
what i'm not gonna
i don't give a [ __ ] i'd like my summer
vacation to begin now by just having not
thinking and just let you just roll over
me so now i'm watching the [ __ ]
kardashians and i gotta tell you
something the [ __ ] american psycho
looking dude
scott first of all i gotta respect that
man's drinking game
he got shit-faced with one of the
kardashians
brother they were [ __ ] pounding
pounding drinks and he got absolutely
hammered and he just went off the
[ __ ] rails
and was doing like a stand-up set
shit-faced just trashing everybody
trashing this woman
hey sweetheart don't look at my [ __ ]
look at his [ __ ] he was out of his
wearing a rope he was out of his [ __ ]
mind
it was tremendous tremendous until
until he was shit-faced that night
and he was telling this old waiter to
shut the [ __ ] up he took a hundred
dollar bill and
stuffed it into his mouth and the
the waiter didn't swing on him he didn't
say anything you know he's a [ __ ]
working the kardashian vip thing he's
working his tip
he's probably thinking i got two i'm
thinking i got too much to lose
and that's the moment the people who
have nothing to [ __ ] lose
do not have you know what i should have
said
they could have a segment going you know
i shouldn't have said that i shouldn't
have done that right so this [ __ ] guy
so i
i really i had a ton of empathy for that
guy he's out there busting his ass and
that [ __ ]
drunk [ __ ] you know belittled him
and the second i thought i was like i
know exactly what that feels like that
guy getting that money stuffed in his
[ __ ] mouth i know exactly what he's
gonna be
i should have why didn't i [ __ ] punch
him it's gonna make him hate himself
uh but we've all been there which is the
purpose of this [ __ ] segment things i
should have said number one hey billy
bagpipe i like that that's a new one
i listened to the recent podcast and
thought about uh
and thought of the worst things i ever
blurted out
well that's that's that should be things
i shouldn't have said
jesus christ you guys are like me you
don't even listen um all right i'll read
it anyways it was kind of funny
years later but still pretty stupid i
was in high school in the early 2000s i
was heavily bullied
one day during math class an
announcement was made that everyone from
my gym class had to report to a lecture
hall
i had no idea why and later found out it
was because
someone stole money as i stood up to
leave my math class and report to my
lecture hall
my annoying bully classmates started
asking why
and making jokes at my expense
i got sick of it and said we all bombed
the school
oh boy i was pulled out of my next class
after math by a social worker
she started asking me about my home life
oh god now it's your parents fault
because of what i said i explained that
i was joking but she said it was a big
deal and she would have to talk to my
mom who was picking me up
i started crying oh god
and then you cried on top of it these
are the things these are the stories
that all great men have
this is what we're all running from
these moments
uh this is what we're compensating for
you started crying i've been there
because i was afraid of being grounded
i was in fact grounded for a month which
is plenty of time to learn how to build
a bomb
what are your parents thinking the next
day my principal told me i would either
get a
get three days in school suspension or
five days out
i chose out i like that
i like that decision there you go there
you go he said i was not getting an
expulsion hearing
because i had no past behavior issues
he was also like i also don't want to
have to [ __ ] you know
look under my car every time i started
up and change my routine how i go home
that's what the principal's thinking
um if i said this now i probably would
have been expelled
definitely do not recommend saying the b
word in a public place for any reason
i hope to catch you in a city near me
soon okay people this is like things i
should have said
but if you want to say things i
shouldn't have said we can do that
segment too i don't i'm easy i don't
give a [ __ ]
i'm watching the kardashians i don't
give a [ __ ] anymore my i'm
completely sold out all right number two
dear billy eats too much cake [ __ ] tits
burr
well that was just you know too long to
be funny but you know just enough detail
to be mean
all right hey hi i am 28 year old male
uh 28 years old was the last time i had
abs and i'll tell you right where i lost
them i went to that carny hot dog
[ __ ] train car
and i went in there somebody goes have
you ever tried chili cheese fries and i
said no i have not
and i ate those [ __ ] thing and my
belly has been distended ever since
but they were delicious speaking of
which i went back there the uh yesterday
or two days ago um
because i was hungry i needed something
quick and what's better than a hot dog
quick right and they had the uh the red
baron oh freckles
oh fire engine red freckles got the red
baron
was absolutely delicious i got one it
was perfect
and shout out to them all right
anyway hi i'm a 28 year old male and i
have a what i should have said story
a few years back i worked with the girl
and because of the laws of proximity and
horniness
we started dating
both our jobs conveniently started
ending at the same time so we were both
looking for jobs at a similar time as
well
i found a job pretty quickly while she
went through interviews
finally after a few months she found a
pretty awesome job and they hired her
good for her right well little did i
know
she would turn into a total [ __ ] because
power
and psychopaths mix like coke and booze
did she meet a new guy at the job i'm
guessing well we traded stories about
our new job and she constantly one-upped
me
she even would brag about how she was
making more money right to my face
oh god there we go that's a that's a
great one
this is what feminists would say well
you should be strong enough
you should be strong it's like well if a
guy was making more money than you and
he threw it in your face would you enjoy
that
that's different why is that hairy leg
[ __ ] person because it happened to me
[Music]
all right one day as the relationship
was ending and i was finding
self-respect again
we were riding in the car and she was
being [ __ ] as usual she blurted out i
always tell my co-workers that if they
ever need me my door is
always open now now at the time i didn't
really respond
because i still wanted a banger but this
made me lose
it on the inside literally as soon as
she got out of the car and was out of
earshot i said to myself
well [ __ ] you work in a [ __ ] cubicle
so you don't have much of a choice
it was just the last straw in a series
of ridiculous bragging from her
anyway i think about that at least once
a month i kind of want to call her
just to say it but [ __ ] it water under
the bridge i guess
um yeah dude it's it is that and you had
a great line too
i mean dude if you did that right then
and then broke up with her on top of
that
there's a reason why that happens in
movies
because it's a movie it's not real to
[ __ ] be able to do that
in real time
i remember one time i was on this uh
i think i've told this story before
that's all my stories at this point when
you do a
podcast solo for the better part of
[ __ ] two decades
um i did this uh
this trip it was me my brother my
grandmother at the time
i know we were great grandkids okay
she was alone at the time we said hey
we're gonna go see the southwest why
don't you come along with us right
so she we take her to all the tourist
sites during the day and at night me and
my brother would go out and get ripped
you know we had a great [ __ ] time
so anyway but we brought her along grand
canyon and all of that [ __ ] so one point
we went into some [ __ ] restaurant
somewhere around the grand canyon and we
went in there and there was some [ __ ]
waitress
and she [ __ ] hated her job and she
was being
it was so i look back to it now it was
almost like an snl character
and she was just going like she was like
can i help you
would you like anything to drink like
she was talking
to us like that right so finally it came
around to me
and i just go uh yeah can i get a 2x
over easy
uh some bacon and uh some toast
she goes what kind of toast and i go
white toast
right and it got real [ __ ] quiet and
she glared at me
and i glared at it for half a second and
then i looked away because i was like uh
it's just gonna be i don't even know why
i [ __ ] i bitched up i looked away
but uh when she left i remember my
grandmother
was very proud of me she you know her
old [ __ ] you know
live through the depression grip grab my
hand
i go is that too much and she goes no to
her her attitude is terrible
oh her attitude is terrible because that
was she came up in the time when the
customer was always right
then i'm not gonna lie to you man i kept
my eye on her the whole time when she
was making my toast to make sure she
didn't [ __ ] spit on it
but that that's the closest i think i
ever came to
in in real before i became like a
comedian
um and i can do it on stage just because
that's what you have to do i learned to
do that but still offstage i still can't
i still don't do it i still don't do it
i can i can definitely
like you know do a tirade of f-bombs
you know and then make whatever what
whatever the other person just did pale
in comparison to whatever the [ __ ] i
just said
i'm not talking about not being able to
i've done that
you know because of this time i can't
even say what the [ __ ] i said
um but i actually this guy ugh i'm gonna
tell this story at some point i'm just
gonna tell a story
but i have to tell it to someone who's
gay
what i said to this guy in a crosswalk
that i almost ran over because i didn't
see him and i tried to apologize to him
and he wouldn't have it
uh whatever i'll tell that story someday
all right number three
hey billy see hey billy see see-through
tits
ah jesus christ
i love it keep fat shaming me i'm on my
way
i already dropped [ __ ] weight once
you stop eating cake you know when you
drink a smoothie it's just [ __ ] you
go for walks it melts away
uh i thought i'd chime in on the passive
aggressive [ __ ] segment you got going on
here a few years ago i got out of the
navy
and went to a bar in my hometown i
hadn't been to it in years
it was full of people i went to high
school with and for the most part i got
a pretty warm welcome
however one guy wasn't so happy to see
the attention i was getting there's
always that guy
he was the rich kid at my school who
never made it out of that town
ah oh that's a tale that's as [ __ ]
long as you're [ __ ] i don't know what
all right
short of the long he sits down next to
me and loudly says
so what exactly did you do over there
referring to my time in the navy i
replied with a short job description
he replied with oh so nothing that
important
he smiled and looked around at the other
people sitting at the bar
in my drunken happiness to be home with
friends and family i didn't catch the
slight until days later
ah the thoughts i have about that are
criminal
and luckily things happen the way they
did
uh thanks for the podcast and go [ __ ]
yourself i know dude you just carry that
you just carry that i know what what do
you wish you would have said to that guy
oh so nothing that important yeah
yeah i was inspired by what you've been
doing with your life
or something i'd say that's thanks too
what do you say to that guy i think you
got to go clint eastwood
just [ __ ] knock him out right oh so
nothing that important
yeah i can't give you any of my old
school responses because all those words
you can't say anymore you get cancelled
and that's the way it is that is the way
it is
um all right so here we go
the montreal canadiens
you know it's kind of funny though you
know when you really think about it that
the montreal canadiens have been around
as long as they have and vegas is a new
team
but they have so established themselves
you got to give it up to the vegas
nights how much they've established
themselves
so quickly going to the nhl finals um
stanley cup finals i don't know whatever
their first year was a couple two three
years ago
um was that against the uh
capitals i want to say yes it was 2018.
um i don't know
we will see we will see what happens but
uh
i was like everybody else going this is
going to be vegas and tampa in the final
and all of a sudden it's looking like is
it going to be the islanders
and canadians way back in the [ __ ]
day that the people that
ended and then the canadians could
avenge the fact that the islanders ended
their almost decade-long dominance
um of the nhl well they sort of shared
the dominance with
tampa tampa with toronto until 1967 i
don't know
all right guys i'm all alone in the
house right now and i'm just starting to
babble
you know beyond what i usually do
here on the podcast um
so i came up a little bit short it's
only 54 minutes but you know what
god damn it it is [ __ ]
it is uh father's day ah [ __ ] i'll
tough it out i'll do another [ __ ]
five minutes for you
all right you wanna hear the music i've
been i've been playing
for my kid uh so i've been playing with
the kingston trio
and some glenn campbell this this song
called gentle
on my mind and i kind of got into this
song because i saw him
there's a if you go on youtube and you
watch him play it live
and uh you see willie nelson and all
these guys just sitting there watching
and playing it's [ __ ] amazing like
um but the [ __ ] lyrics
it's a really sad song to the point i'm
like
is this like is this just me or is this
song really [ __ ] sad it's kind of
about this guy
who has this chick that he really loves
you know but he's always away and he's
not near her but she's uh when he thinks
of her
she's always gentle on his mind which
means he loves her
so the whole [ __ ] song i'm like well
then what the [ __ ] are you going all
around everywhere why don't you go home
to her
the song was making me sad and i
realized like oh wait a minute this is
what the [ __ ] i did
this is how i [ __ ] up a bunch of
relationships
this is how like i you know that's how
[ __ ] up i was as a
as a kid when there was a girl that i
liked
rather than going over and saying hello
and asking her out i just started
fantasizing
about me playing the electric guitar or
something or
[ __ ] being a comedian or i don't know
what
[ __ ] running into a house fire i
would just have these hero fantasies
right and even in the hero fantasy i
never talked to her she just saw me do
what i did and then that was it
i was a [ __ ] mess so
i'm just sitting there reading the
lyrics
oh this is the wrong song this is a song
called dreams of the everyday
housewife which uh if you want to know
why the woman's movement ever happened
just read those [ __ ] lyrics jesus
christ
um it's like a tribute to the woman who
just gives up everything that she ever
had and now she's old and she's looking
at old pictures of her when
guys were all interested in her and now
they're not now she's just a wrinkled
housewife
and she gave it all up for me and my
dreams i mean there's there's a
you know as much as a dick as i am i
it's not like i don't understand where
all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] from the ladies is coming from um
oh jeep bill thank you for extending the
olive branch you freckled con you're
welcome
um all right here's gentle on my mind uh
let me read some of these sad [ __ ]
lyrics
it's knowing that your door is always
open and your path is free to walk
that makes me tend to leave my sleeping
bag rolled up and stashed behind your
couch
so i'm like all right good he's settling
down
and it's knowing i'm not shackled by
forgotten words and bonds
and the ink stains that have dried upon
some lines
that keep you in the back roads by the
rivers of my memory
and keep you ever gentle on my mind so
i'm like oh wait what the [ __ ]
the back roads of your memory
no the back roads and by the rivers of
your memory like she's in your past
so i feel bad for this guy because it's
like
well stop [ __ ] running around like a
goddamn idiot
and why don't you go to this person and
you know why
because he can't
he doesn't know how to love
so instead he's when i walk around some
railroad track
and find that you're moving on this
[ __ ] guy he's on railroad tracks
where else is he and still might run in
silence tears of joy might stain my face
this is when he's hammered thinking
about how much he loves her mumbling
saying all the [ __ ] he should have said
to her but now he's saying it next to
some [ __ ] hobo in a campfire
and the summer sun might burn me till
i'm blind
but not to where i cannot see you
walking on the back roads by the rivers
flowing gentle on my mind
ah jesus christ
and these songs will continue to be
written
until it's acceptable for a man to
acknowledge
that crying is actually a a viable
[ __ ] emotion
that you're supposed to use as opposed
to [ __ ] pushing her down
and going playing a contact sport you
know
and [ __ ] you know i don't know
beating the [ __ ] out of some
[ __ ] weaker kid who then stands up
and makes a bomb threat in the [ __ ]
math class
sorry it's all connected but anyway the
song's called
gentle on my mind by glenn campbell
you should check it out and uh
i don't know if you're living that life
you know it's never too late to turn it
around maybe you could go cheer up that
[ __ ] waitress in arizona that i had
30 [ __ ] years look at me i'm tying it
all
the loose ends up with 19 seconds to go
like the milwaukee bucks here you guys
didn't think i was gonna pull out a full
hour
well guess what i did that's it that's
the monday morning podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves
and i will check in on you on uh
what is what is the day after wednesday
sorry i gotta make an hour it's uh
thursday bam i did an hour all right
happy father's day everybody i'll see